I look like I died because I did on a
game called subnautica you have been
sucked deep into the ocean I played for
13 hours straight this weekend
I regret some of it it's it's the type
of game where you can just get lost and
then everything else in your real life
doesn't exist I'm one of those people
and as for you though it gets in trouble
you like ma'am open up where are your
children like I don't know okay clowning
on that game when Jason was playing it
first I was like why is he playing so
much then you tried it and then you did
the same thing well because it appeals
to the same kind of person it's like
someone that likes just gathering things
and in completing tasks that's me it's
bad it's really bad I don't like either
of those things but I do like wine and
if you like wine like me you can try
wink I'm going to try wink coms last
general Julianne they pick out wine
specifically for your tastes and send it
to your front door okay all right
you get why gry winc calm Jenna Julianne
$20 off and they'll handle the shipping
guys check it out it's worth it really
cool service great wine also guys
tracker instead of losing your prized
devices and wallets and keys and
backpacks and electronics just put a
tracker on it a tracker pixel to be
specific a tracker pixels it's a tiny
device that connects to your phone's app
on the tracker app you buy it and it
lasts and it saves you a whole bunch of
headache and it gives you peace of mind
guys go to tracker this th e TR ACK our
comm slash I'm doing get 20% off any
order check it out or click the link in
our description I'm going in another
track girl because I just got a new
backpack along with this fleece which
I'm not taking off you've worn that
fleece since you got it this I'm not
taking it off okay it's my favorite item
of clothing it goes beautifully with my
[ __ ] hair rat [ __ ]
there's a naked dog on top of the
counter carpets under here he's crying
peach jumped up on my desk and marbles
is walking around like is anyone gonna
get me okay
well they'll sort it out we have
important business to do today it might
be a shorter podcast at agent Safeway I
guess but we have a couple of vine
quizzes that I think we should do
because we haven't taken these yet and a
while ago someone tweeted them at these
out this was a vine quiz yeah what's her
name on Twitter because she tweeted at
me
ouch I'm on Twitter I'm on Twitter but
then the one I printed out was one that
sort of like blew up on Twitter a while
ago let me find the name of that person
so I can give them cred
hi Carmy can you sit with me I'm sorry
signed I'll see you later
my and DX on Twitter it got like 76
thousand retweets don't pick them up you
know it makes for great parenting
divided rules anyway we're gonna do the
printed out version first
ya know somebody tweeted me that they
write your name on your test please so
Cho somebody somebody tweeted at me out
Drive on Twitter that she had made a
vine jeopardy quiz and that we should do
it on the podcast and I was like that
sounds like a great plan because I love
vine I've always loved vine I was like
the one person that was using vine until
the day it shut down and just on their
refreshing pages looking for things to
laugh at cuz it genuinely made me laugh
harder than anything like how many
videos would you recorded me actual cry
laughing at vines a lot you were a vine
it was bad but I feel like vine jokes
now that it's been a few years are
somehow getting funnier well they also
like it's one of those like the humor of
vine wasn't really popularized in wild
vine was around but now that it's gone
there's all these vine compilations and
like you seen these compilations of like
vines that make my life great you know
like things like that but like you were
dying at those when they when they were
on bye
yeah my oh I feel like all of those
contain all of the same vines and some
of
weren't even like popular online yeah
but whatever peach go away PG everyone
leave stop standing on me all right now
we're ready for this though I feel like
I'm gonna do well a period I'm in third
period weight question your nameday and
their peers I'm not I'm not in the third
period I'm in fourth period jenna mourey
you have a like a gray space of body
covering a date the 29th verb for you
who's just wrote um 1:29 31 like I
thought it was 20 31 maybe you are
living in 2031 fourth period right oh
wait I've marked it in the wrong way
okay sure question one all right are you
ready play along okay question one you
read the first question
wait so are we doing this together are
we both teeth we answer we're answering
we're not telling each other our answer
we're reading the questions of the
question section one choose the best
answer tries to complete the following
vines this is guys this is what it looks
like all right looks like i got proper
quiz like that girl [ __ ] really did
it
you almost made me drop my blank a
lizard
be croissant see snack D sandwich easy
question number two I blank you [ __ ] I
ain't never gonna stop blank you [ __ ]
hey hey slash hatin B kiss / kissing see
like / like indeed love / 11 alright if
you get anything less than 100% there's
no way it can get less than 100% hold on
let's bet what happens if you if you get
less than a hundred percent um actually
now that I'm looking at question three
question number three says that fufu
lame [ __ ] I blank
I'll send some shots at your fitted
blank eight with it gratata got it yeah
boy love it I love you or get my juice
well there's also no answer key we don't
have an answer key actually I know the
answers that I know
we recently it's our number four hi my
name is Trey and I have a blank tomorrow
a baseball game the soccer game see
basketball game and D spelling bee it's
definitely spelling bee didn't mmm I
never went to a blow job question four
wait there's two question force
question four again [ __ ] this [ __ ]
caught me blink I said [ __ ] where she
said under all that blank I said [ __ ]
oh where Hey ugly / makeup be rude /
energy C b /b benson d suck / rats
5 can I get a blank hey hello bee oh
yeah see wah-wah-wah-wah got deep is it
6 my name is Blake
hey Jackson John James or Jeff oh man
question number 7 next time you put your
[ __ ] blank on me I'm a [ __ ] rip
your blank off [ __ ] eyes dick arms legs
hands face mouth tongue next time you
put your I think C is the only one that
make sense what'd you get I'm just
thinking this is a quiz
no sharing answers Julian don't look at
my paper I just got one question Blake
okay all four are what are those Oh for
the same answer they all say what are
those I know what I'm picking 9 oh my
god you spilled my blank in my Valentin
you spilled blank in my Valentino bag
mascara lip gloss lipstick or juice
is that real what is that referring to a
dog a stupid rock a free taco or a rat
peach I swear to god peach
get out of here go well come on ray
section true set are you ready for
section two she wants this credibly
naughty
okay yeah select true or false for the
following you mean less I'm sorry
is that real or is that referring to hmm
okay got it
all right select true or false okay
number one a child is worse than a
rapist this is a trick question
this is your question I'm the number two
this [ __ ] empty you are my dad you
never want to hear something ugly-ass
noodle head number four a potato flew
around my room before you came excuse
the mess it made peach excuse okay you
know this is interrupting our work now
number five I love how people are
telling me I'm like two nine years old
I'm 11 so shut the [ __ ] up number six
I'm gonna say it I care that you broke
your elbow number seven [ __ ] off Janet
I'm not going to your baby shower
number eight we're going too fast
you are disrespecting a future US Army
soldier I'm surprised there was no
question on here that says I've been to
you jobber okay how do we hurry fact
check this this is I don't know this is
the hard part
yeah okay well number one you almost
made me drop Microsoft I saw you almost
made me drop my Chris all right yeah
[ __ ] I never gonna stop loving you
[ __ ] all right two for two that fufu
lame [ __ ] I ain't with it I'll send some
shots BAE your fitted gratata that's
what I put two I hope that's it that's
it but I never really listen to what
he's saying before now English just oh I
didn't see you guys there hi my name is
Trey I love best
what are you okay yeah I just thought we
were talking and then I like forgot that
sorry I have to be playing along I
didn't know you guys were there okay
basketball game obviously this [ __ ]
called me ugly I said [ __ ] why she said
under all that makeup I said [ __ ] we're
okay whatever fine are you just like
going through it like yeah those are the
easy ones what some people are listening
to the podcast making their own answers
okay go ahead then number four number
two this witch called me ugly I said
[ __ ] way she said under all that makeup
I said it's weird you love that line no
you okay number five I have no idea what
that is
oh yeah well I got a right I guess I
think that's it okay can I get a hoe
yeah so that's B my name is Jeff correct
all right so I'm seven four seventy one
of those six questions on the first
number seven next time you put put your
[ __ ] I put hands face mm-hmm next
time you put your [ __ ] hands on me
I'm gonna rip your [ __ ] face off
[ __ ] yeah it's a kid that says that
he's in a bathroom I remember that one I
just got one question hey what are those
B what are those see what are those are
D what are those
you can't get it wrong I put B what you
put everybody's getting an A today what
the curve is in our favor
oh my god you spilled the blank in my
Valentino bag I think it's lipstick but
I don't remember
tbh I'll google it right now I'll be the
faculty vine fact-checked err sector you
spilled um I never went over Java you
spilled lipstick is the lipstick yeah
yeah first one
why'd you put juice
cuz it is that real what is that
referring to a rat it's a rat put it to
hog no you didn't I did what's wrong
with you it's like sitting on a bunch of
soda like boxes of soda or something and
it's just a little rat and this when we
walk spangles no real dammit okay moving
on to true or false number a number one
a child is worse than a rapist I don't
understand I said that this was a trick
question because in the vine it says
there's only one thing worse than a
rapist and that's a child and they said
mmediately says no so that means he's
wrong so a child is worse than rapist is
false but I put true I feel like this is
a trick question so you could either
argue for truth no no no we're gonna
dive into this one okay according to the
vine it is a child the only thing worse
than a rapist is moves down the sheet a
child and he says no that means a child
is not worse than a rapist meaning this
is false I completely disagree and
Franklin nice to meet you the whole
point of the vine is that he says a
child is worse than a rapist yes but
what's with the no at the end of it then
well that's why I'm saying you could
interpret it either way but I'm not
agreeing but the answer is false
I'm not I'm not agreeing that answer is
true well then we both get it right but
I get plus two no you don't no no no you
don't absolutely not
no cuz you just want to win and you're
not you have two questions wrong no he
just wrote see me after class with a
winky face on his own quiz that's gross
and weird all right you know this [ __ ]
empty true true as hell
that's a T I just there's a actually I
think it's a T then what's that second
line is underlined no no absolutely not
you got another one
no it was an underlying team no it's not
I'm seeing teacher after class I'll
explain okay you are my dad you never
want to hear something ugly-ass noodle
hands fall it's absolutely false true
absolutely true I love how people are
telling me I'm like two nine years old
I'm 11 so shut the [ __ ] up that's true
absolutely true
I'm gonna say it I care that you broke
your elbow false
I do not care that you broke your elbow
[ __ ] off Janet I'm not going to your
baby shower true you are disrespecting a
future u.s. army shoulder sure true
alright so I won there's not a bad quiz
ouch it's actually pretty good
ouch I'm on Twitter no this is an
outcome on Twitter this is the other
girl I just shot it out
oh [ __ ] out on Twitter is the digital
one [ __ ] that's alright I got no I got a
hundred you didn't get anyone wrong I
think three got three wrong but one of
them said see me after class so I'll
just say two wrong I'll 11 12 13 14 15
16 18 19 so 17 out of 19 hey Siri what's
17 divided by 19 oh my god hey Siri
what's 17 divided by 19 yes b-plus 89%
baby
so are you writing see me after class
again see me before class
oh you got an A+ I got a b-plus all good
piece why are you on the counter why
don't you come over here let's take
another quiz how many is Jenna I'm 31
and today I'm only taking vine quizzes
is it her you can't be on top of it get
over here come here it comes
the community does wait oh we planed
vine jeopardy or the other vine quiz
will do vine Jeopardy last because
that's probably I think the best one
cuz it was made by ending don't do that
I never went over Java all right so
we're doing the BuzzFeed one first these
are too easy
we're gonna link the quiz older look
this is literally way too easy
the the buzz he wants yeah I smell like
beef
I smell like Dino if this is too easy
yes it is no there's a lot I don't know
there's pictures I'm in my mom's car
blank get out me car vroom vroom beep
beep honk honk Zoom Zoom we linked it
right so if you want to play a lot of
those it's beep beep we're take we're
taking it alone and then we'll see what
our score your reaction was when I said
it's pp look at all those chickens Brock
wrong a doctor right away soldiers
why the [ __ ] you lyin why are you always
lying ok mm-hmm my god holy [ __ ] dude
I'm serious
well I got why are you just gonna take
the whole quiz what okay officer I've
got one question for you who dressed you
where did you buy these what are those
and why blank James King Rick LeBron
Kevin I smell like cheese Beefeater
front what was that Julian
beef you say that like a thousand done I
smell like me it is blank time to
[ __ ] party Wednesday or Spidey time
hmm hi welcome to hell [ __ ] hi welcome
to the Thunderdome hi welcome to Chili's
hi welcome to your nightmare
all the above blank Richard why Richard
what are you doing Richard what the [ __ ]
Richard dare you Richard honestly I
don't remember blank I was crazy back
then
I was probably too I was probably [ __ ]
up I was way too young it was so long
ago
it's all so hazy nut I'm watching blank
[ __ ] VM I closed my whole self the
weird off me my sins their their daddy's
here daddy's got you
not psyche bruh yeah right
blank a maker dance bands pants beans
peas [ __ ] [ __ ] I got one wrong you won't
let me in my car how is this safe te gas
money what I'm just reading there's more
I'm not giving up that was legitness
radical epical intensity way tomorrow on
that one yet sorry you won't let me in
the car how is this safe do you need gas
when anyone's there what do you expect
yeah I'm getting some of these wrong
yeah me too
we should go to fight in jeopardy this
one's weird and it's also like boring
for the podcast I feel that's what I'm
saying
yeah because they can't see the pictures
unless they're playing along yeah that's
true okay okay oh my god I love Chipotle
Chipotle is my life I think this is just
us saying vine quotes over and over
again okay fact I'll I'm going to the
next one yeah it really is that that's
what I mean from the podcast perspective
that's probably what it sounds like
mm-hmm but if your name is jr. and
you're really handsome calm I'll raise
your hand what the [ __ ] is up Kyle no
see it's step the [ __ ] up all right I
switched I moved to jeopardy camera I'm
just saying there's no no I'm just
saying viral sort of give the link to
this too
okay I'm going hi how many teams no
device okay two teams do you want to
play in buzzer mode yeah up click
upgrade to pro 2
my server solution okay to team captains
god please hold him he's crying he's a
sad guy he needs a hug if your name is
Carmen and you're really handsome come
on cries a mark that's when you cry come
here Carmen
Wow guess who ate lots of watermelon yet
City yeah I hope it doesn't give you
diarrhea yeah you can't eat too much or
else we'll get diarrhea it's a little
bit just a little watermelon huh do you
see his tongue he's a good boy I
understand we all need hug cuz it's not
mobile friendly or something I'm trying
to figure this out request that stops
out let's try that again yep your name
is Kermit and you're really handsome
come I stick your tongue out Wow well if
we can't play out mobile then we can
just talk about Souza my queen who I
waited the Grammys maybe wait a long
time just to see her perform like come
on I don't have all [ __ ] night
I got other [ __ ] to do and I love her
every time that I went and rode my bike
this past summer I was only listening to
her album on my bicycle it was amazing
if you see a 31 year old lady riding a
light blue bike with a whale on the
handle listening this is a music that is
me not just a whale though it's a whale
that's disguised as well but is really a
bike horn yeah you squeeze it it's a
it's a horn to tell other people look
the [ __ ] out mm-hmm my bike uh
says it was dope Kesha was amazing at
the Grammys yeah I saw somebody tweet
that was like um not to throw shade or
anything well like catches the ball
goals weren't that good come on Finn
come on Finn
yeah come on as she's like immediately
broke down in tears after her but I was
so intense though yeah well it's just
like literally reliving hell and I was
performing it that's why I said
and then Bruno Mars absolutely destroyed
I'm so proud of are we all proud of it
so funny that like years ago like we
made fun of brats mom for saying that he
was ultimate showman when he's like
literally that and in more now I feel
like that's just a funny thing for a
middle-aged woman to say about Bruno
Mars circa circa 2014 no not even then
like 2012 right Earth 2013 she was like
that Bruno Mars women oh no she said it
years before though right yeah yeah so
like six years ago I just think it's
really funny for someone to call someone
else the ultimate showman as if like
they're a magician or like they run a
circus or something if you were to
change one thing about the Grammys to
make him more exciting what would you be
what would it be I would make it so
instead of a red carpet it's it's a it's
a red the red carpet while I'm here and
you have to sprint to the top of the
hill and the loser doesn't get in it's
it's hill sprints
so you're dressing your shoes in your
outfit it has not only to be really
good-looking but very functional
functional cuz you're gonna be in a
one-on-one race with an undetermined
opponent you arrive out of your limo you
get paired up right away and then
someone shoots the air gun in there and
you sprint up the hill and if you get to
the top of the red carpet first on the
hill it's at a 14% grade it's very very
steep a lot of people tripping over
themselves then you then you get in and
what what do you think I hate it what
throw a little athletic competition it
sounds like a liability
why how would anyone get hurt how how is
Sidney Lauper beating anybody into the
Grammys you never lose anybody a little
bit older getting into the crotch maker
works tirelessly tirelessly for months
to figure out who matches against who
and when they arrive they have the
hardest job in the history of Arrietty
Matchmaker doesn't there's a new job
from the they all race up the
carpet no it's one-on-one races it's not
everyone it would take forever oh that's
that's the beauty of it what is that's
the beauty how many people do you think
are at the Grammys um thousand well I
don't know we're talking about how many
people walk the red carpet how many
people do you think walk the red carpet
I don't have an estimate for that
okay Google know how many people walk
it's like not just the artists it's
their PR people it's their managers
their agents with talent one talent
races only no agents but how would those
people gonna get into the Grammys then
they meet him there's a side route but
you just said the only way in was this
silly way out for the for the talent and
then you didn't hear my second part of
it though not only do they win the way
into the Grammys but the fastest time of
the night wins album of the year come on
that's exciting well I mean if that was
the case then I am a prince are only
three oh my if I was Usain Bolt I would
put out the shittiest piece of music
just gonna [ __ ] everybody up but
everyone has a bad night whose hand
could have a bad night you never know
what's printing against other musicians
yeah also the Academy chooses the
outfits so that if if Hussein with them
to be in there maybe this whole
conversation is like making my chest
type stop I cata me award I'm offering
you the position the coveted position of
sprint Matchmaker all year long you have
to work tirelessly with coordinating
with everyone who's going to be at the
Grammys in advance without even knowing
and then you have to line them up at
specific time slots and you have to race
them
do you accept I'm not kidding these
conversations making you say we paid
three hundred sixty-five dollars a year
it's making my chest tight actually
three hundred sixty-four dollars you get
one day off from one vacation of the
whole year you better be back early in
the morning 9:00 a.m. I can't talk
anymore
my arms are getting tight though it's
like spreading through my body okay I
got a new suggestion a new suggestion
okay are you ready I'm gonna leave okay
so when you go to the bar my body to go
to the bar okay
what bar it was a bar inside the Grammys
to get your drink drink
you only can buy drinks with monopoly
money of which you have won at the game
last night
the night before the Grammys there's a
giant Monopoly game everyone who's
involved are up for an award has to play
and the only well the only way you can
drink at the Grammys is if you use your
monopoly money ask me questions about
the logistics I'll clarify any questions
you might have
oh yeah play Monopoly with that many
people yeah you can we have a special
edition of Monopoly minimum six thousand
users the board is massive it's
currently being manufactured I'm getting
hot now it's a hundred yards by eight
hundred rectangles rectangular Monopoly
board mystery okay one more one more
alteration to the Grammys please board
the rest of that wasn't just pure
garbage thinking a rectangular Monopoly
board oh it's so wrong
popcorn will fall from the ceiling well
fall from the ceiling you're itchy
because Kermit's on you he caused his
meeting like no popcorn will fall from
the ceiling so stressed out right now
Wow the Grammys is going on everyone in
the crowd is playing hearthstone
simultaneously listening and watching
while also multitasking in a hearthstone
Mathematica bet okay it turns out that
the Grammys is just a big front for a
hearthstone tournament is gone it's
actually Blizzcon keaney i'm podcasting
i have good ideas and so the winner of
grammy of album of the year is
actually is actually the person who won
the most - match is the thing is okay
you know what the thing is though I lost
my train of thought because this isn't
rachac and is moving on top of me
so say you win the match right mm-hmm
the match is over and then you find out
who you be or who you lost it hmm so
you're gone and you're stoned ended up I
like the idea of a blind hearthstone
tournament let's say Amell after that
match you like you just beat Alicia kid
okay so yeah I feel like that's a good
idea but then you lost me at wins album
of the year okay so when the album of
the Year category this person not only
ran the fastest hill sprint on the road
two hours earlier but they also have the
best win-loss record of hearthstone that
night so if you win the sprint but you
don't if you don't beat everywhere in
hearthstone you banned from from the
Grammys forever you have to be you have
to be it's teaching people to be fast
both on hearthstone and on their feet I
like the idea that if you can't sprint
up a hill you know I'm ready to redeem
your school if you win or fall from the
sky I need space and air I'm hot this is
the worst idea I've ever heard wait why
am I making you hot cuz you're so
frustrated okay
can you give me any advice on on my
ideas I like they work I really enjoy
the idea of a blind like any kind of
blind gaming tournament where you find
out after the game who you just played I
think that's really fun I I don't like
the idea that is at the Grammys or that
whoever wins wins something I don't like
the hill sprint into the Grammys I don't
like any of that I'm just gonna add on
top okay so the hill sprint and the
hearthstone will be separate per your
requests okay you can be slow on your
feet but good at hearthstone and vice
versa and still win things the winner of
album of the year sorry the winner of
album of the year we'll get to implement
their own album on everyone's phone
without the mask
like you to that's what they get okay
because it's so good that's such a good
album they get to force their album on
everyone's phone I'm still mad at you do
for doing that I think it was really
invasive yeah it took me I want to say
like two years the Grammys takes place
on an island and it lasts for four weeks
there's one there's one basket of food
survive and win or die the Grammys is
gonna take place live on musically I
don't know why it's just like making me
so upset
why it's making me so up it's survivor
meets the Grammys everyone starts
looking beautiful in their nice outfits
and ends up looking like they've been on
Survivor for 30 days which they have
because this is survivor it's survived
it's just survivor it's not even agree
it's just survivor well I'm selling you
survivor the show do you buy it no good
good meeting
I'm not buying so I'm just trying to
think of ways to spice it up you know
spice it up you just spice it up every
seat at the Grammys underneath the chair
has a random spice to spice it up some
have oregano some have allspice there's
a bay leaf under one chair they just
throw it in the air yeah oh okay like
instead of confetti they just they make
it rain like paprika or something mm-hmm
a nice mild curry maybe mmm a yellow
curry a person who does the longest
handstand can host doing a host we
better practice Suzanne stands and you
have to host your feet up in the air
your Rob miked up so smoothly like so
tensile nature there's a
crossword puzzle and the person to solve
it first is the only one to get the
Wi-Fi password no one else gets Wi-Fi at
the grammys half an hour there there are
some brainiacs that will solve it very
fast and then no one else gets Wi-Fi the
whole thing will be catered by the DMV
tons of really good food really cold
meatballs of mints oh and pencils a
scantron reader up on top of the stage
everyone fills on their scantron yes
correct number one a number two the
person who comes in last place at the
Grammys because it is it is a numerical
division of how it works you get first
place of the Grammys or last and if you
get last your SAT scores are leaked oh
do you remember like in high school how
big of a deal that was like they really
want to tell anybody yeah kidding me no
like oh god that was the worst that was
the worst how many times you take your
SAT by the way ah I took I think I took
them twice I'm I took a PSA yeah I took
PSAT and then two SATs yeah I think I
took a choice hmm what no I didn't like
the SAT I think I felt like it was just
a bad a bad way of determining someone's
intelligence of course it is just can
you take a test or not that's stupid
my brother got a perfect score on math
like both times he took it and bombed
that English section boy okay my mom
blasts I love putting him on blast
what am I looking dude yeah
you know what else gets put in their
place what anything that you put a
tracker on because it's never lost it's
always at its place you're always losing
your stuff guys make this your different
make it stress for you attractor pick so
worried about losing your things ever
again eight years ago tracker changed
everything when they brought our new
device that tracker and they've done it
again with the new tracker pixel guys
it's the lightest Bluetooth tracking
device on the market it's so tiny when
you order it you get it in your in your
like wait that's gonna attract my [ __ ]
it does any belonging like you like I
put it in my drum bag huge huge amounts
of peace of mind when I travel with my
drone because you never know what's
going on you put it in your camera bag
your wallet your keys if you're moving
put it you know there's so many uses for
and it's really affordable and it's
something that you you know when you
invest in you're gonna thank yourself
for you just press the button on your
tracker pixel and your phone rings if
you lose your phone or if you're trying
to find the item that has the tracker on
you go to the tracker app on your phone
and you locate it with the crowd-sourced
GPS within the app right now guys go to
the tracker that's th e TR ACK our comm
slash engine get 20% off any order and
get started today and you also get a 30
day money back guarantee so you truly
have nothing to lose and once you've
done that relax with a glass of wine
courtesy of wink guys enough going at
the grocery store and trying to pick I'm
trying to pick out wine based on how
cool the bottles look or what that
really ill-informed grocery attendant is
he'll you or even informed honestly
because they might be informed with the
end of the day the team at wink is ultra
informed they are professionals they
know wine in and out you take a pallet
profile quiz on their website you say
what flavors in general that you like
and they form your own custom palette
profile and then they serve you wines
that they know scientifically that
you're gonna like and they ship it to
your door okay so it takes all the
guesswork out of getting good wine you
get it shipped to your door don't do it
wow that was a hard one okay
discover and drink great new wine new
wine this year no discover and drink
good wine guys really
a wine by going to try wink that's T ry
winc
dot-com / annejulien you get $20 off
your first shipment check it out guys
okay and if you don't like a bottle
they'll replace it with a different one
nothing to lose
thank you sponsors for sponsoring the
podcast if you would like to click the
link in the description for either of
our sponsors that'll take you to them
[Music]
okay what can it can I help you oh do
you know what's really cool is when you
you can cool off when you when you um
take a paramotor and you go up above the
clouds because it's way cooler and so
then you just float around amongst
planes and helicopters that cool you off
new new rule anyone who's who's going
for best new artist has to fly in to the
lord show via via aerial transportation
whether it's a paramotor or a skydive or
a parachute or a jet pack or a plane or
a helicopter good thing you'll get in
your gift bag with the grammys some
sweatpants Grammys sweatpants every time
you put them on you'll feel like you're
at the Grammys because they feel like
fancy people and no food and they're one
size fits all I'm just tryna okay the
Grammys hired me I'm their ideas guy I'm
just trying please stop I'm like I'll
stop I'll stop you're gonna make me take
this fleece off I haven't taken the
Grammys but has outstanding traffic
violations they must fill the documents
and and submit payment at the door of
the Grammys otherwise I'm not allowed in
the Grammys is now run by the government
and the DMV if you have any outstanding
parking violations they will be
submitted or you will not be admitted
into the show
number two pencils only into Grammys
that's it the physical award is a
propeller and it turns on if you win
otherwise it's just the stationary
propeller wherever you'd like because
your greatness if you won you get number
one if you get first place at the
Grammys you can go wherever you want
tuck my chair what's so funny I'm hot
and I'm like tingling my chest is tight
my arms are hot my dog took my seat I'm
like sweating it's okay you're wearing a
lot of clothes yeah but it was fine
until you started making up [ __ ] about
the Grammys I don't know why it's just
making me real hot and high V right now
I'm allergic the Grammys takes place in
a giant sauna it's a hundred and three
degrees inside the person who sweats the
most wins the loser gets a free mafia
that's it they get to take a mole feel
why don't we play a game called let's
put that ball a cookie dough here and
see what peach does let's put up here I
want sushi does this we made a bunch of
cookie dough to eat it's like it's it's
good it's freeze it yeah but like Julian
brought me a little ball last night
while I was playing subnautica and I
didn't end up eating it but it's still
here a peach just keeps trying to eat it
desperately you're gonna get it since
you've been trying all Podcast long this
is your this is your chance to go clean
it's mine Queen you can do it
oh we got Kermit and all that - are you
gonna get it
you got to try and get it this is what
she's doing on that side table over
there you're disturbing us on the
podcast see just take it we're not gonna
let her eat it don't worry it's just
like flour and butter and sugar anyways
vegan butter a forever she got it good
speaking of dog guys chef our good
friend Jeff got his first his new dog
this weekend we went and picked little
NOLA up with him and she's adorable and
I just wanted to give him a quick plug
because he's gonna be having her on the
twitch stream so he would like to see go
to Jay Cyrus oh thank you finally for
not talking about the Grammys anymore
you're making my chest way too tight I
feel like I'm gonna go to the hospital I
mean I need the ambulance I need call
now at 4:20 what's your emergency
smoking no I'm not no what what it's so
special like it's just the most special
days of days when you get your dog or
like you know yeah whatever it was it
was cool because we went and picked up
Jeff's dog with him and we got to see
him like interact and meet the dog and
like I know but like it really brought
me back to when I when I picked up Pete
Joey you cried I dog and you cried I
mean it's this tiny she's a tiny little
Shih Tzu she's adorable her name is Noah
but she immediately just gave Jeff like
kisses all over the face anyway that was
our weekend so that's what I wanted to
talk about like it's just uh I feel like
it's so special to be with someone when
they they take a step like that in their
life that's like their new their new
little buddy your best bud yeah it's
like the other part of you it's very
cool and uh yeah I did I cried cuz I
can't help it I didn't think I'm gonna
cry at all I'm like well someone else is
picking
they're puppy and it still makes me cry
I was just really sweet and touching
interesting and I just like it was sweet
it was like it's a great moment I was so
bad Julianne oh well guys if you're free
tonight you're not doing anything we're
gonna be streaming live on the up G
twitch channel doing some charity work
we're gonna stream for charity tonight
just pluck about really quick because
it's a cool thing no it is cool if you
want to different streamers yeah so
basically battlegrounds the the Twitter
account of pub G is giving their channel
to bunch of streamers for 24 hours to
raise money for charity it's a really
great cause go to our twitter account at
Jenna Julian not agenda Julian pot just
at Jenna Julian on Twitter we have
details there but I will see you guys on
twitch tonight those are you gonna be
there it'd be pretty cool and thanks for
putting up with us for a funky podcast
I never went over job she's fine rabbit
hey it's not for you I'm just I'm just
teasing you oh my god PG we have to
brush your teeth at sugar it's not good
for you okay alright
peachy okay thanks for watching bye guys
[Music]
you
[Music]